Bill Gates.
-Your favorite animal?
-Dog.
-Your favorite food?
-Hamburger.
-Eat breakfast?
-Nothing.
What is your worst fear?
I don't want my brain
to stop working.
Bill is a multiprocessor.
He'll be reading
something else
but then processing
at the same time.
It's chaos!
He thrives on complexity.
He makes a framework
in his mind
and then he starts
slotting in the information.
If something doesn't line up,
he gets really frustrated.
It's scary.
But when Bill stills himself,
he can pull ideas together
that other people can't see.
At Microsoft,
I worked night and day.
That was how I made sure
Microsoft stayed ahead.
I could be so extreme.
You never understood
the first thing about this!
Microsoft hit a new
record high on Wall Street.
Rivals paint a dark picture.
He'll do whatever he can
to capture more of the market.
Our mother wanted him
to focus
on community and family.
I gave my mom a hard time
not following what she wanted.
You don't raise a family
hyper-focused in your head.
Each one of us has to start out
with developing his or her
own definition of success.
I had the wrong way
of looking at things.
In life, you have to decide,
what's important in the world?
I will look at energy,
climate change,
and disease eradication.
It's important that we start
deploying solutions
unnaturally fast.
We are running out
of time here.
He tends to look at problems
from unusual angles.
There hasn't been innovation
in nuclear energy for 25 years.
What are the odds
of getting the job done?
If you want to make
a dent in this,
you better think
in wholesale magnitudes.
He's at his best
when the deck is stacked
against him.
There's many challenges.
This is harder than I expected.
Ultimately,
it's not what you get...
it's what you become.